so I just saw the disaster artist based
on the hit book by Greg Sestero and Tom
Bissell who I feel does not get enough
credit he did co-author this book so he
definitely deserves credit for that
and yeah I've been trying to get a lot
of credit to this film and try to tell
everybody about it and the book when it
first came out and stuff like that not
realizing I didn't have to uh this
really really is blowing up and people
are talking ask your buzz about it's
getting great critical response the
audience I saw it with loved it I saw it
at the Music Box in Chicago they do a
screening of the room every month so
they were laughing at scenes even before
they happen cuz they knew what was gonna
come of it uh so a part of me was
wondering should I start off this review
with the Tommy was so wig and doing the
voice and stuff like that and I decided
no because where the room is very much
Tommy Wiseau's accomplishment this is
very much Greg Sestero as accomplishment
I don't mind making fun Tommy was so but
Greg Sestero is a really cool guy super
sweet has been very supportive of us
loved the review of the room anytime
Tommy Wiseau comes after us with like a
lawsuit or whatever he tries to take us
down he's usually good enough to go and
sort of you know talk with them and
stuff like that and just so we don't
have enough nice things to say about
Greg Sestero and he really did write a
fantastic book definitely go check that
down now that you've probably gone to
check out this movie so and my thoughts
on this movie yeah what what everyone's
saying is right it's a really great
movie it's captured the soul of the book
very much any problems I have with it
are nitpicky you know it's one of those
things where I'll say this it was very
surreal this is the first time I've seen
a movie where I know the main character
and it's played by a different person
that's very surreal you know I'll watch
dave Franco perform as Greg Sestero and
I'll be a little Greg doesn't really
sound
like that or great that when you know
really do that it's like it's a movie
this is a fine performance uh both him
and James you know give fine
performances and are both wonderful like
it it's just weird it's jarring cuz it's
the first time I've ever like come
across that song Amelie like well he
doesn't do that or he'd I mean nothing
like me and sister are like super close
but I mean like it's it's a little weird
when you know someone do you see them
being portrayed on the big screen but
he's wonderful he's definitely the
straight man to James Franco as Tommy
was so James Franco is ridiculously good
and while clarify what I mean by that
because I think people think they're
gonna see this movie and see like you
know something that's gonna it's gonna
be like the end of cocoa it's gonna make
you cry it's gonna be really
gut-wrenching it's not quite that it
that that's not the kind of good it is
but it's not just an impression either
James Franco really does well at getting
you know knowing the mannerisms and the
voice so creepy how close the voice is I
think the only ER person I've seen do a
better Tommy Wiseau is Greg Sestero who
does a really amazing Tommy Wiseau but
but but he I hate using this phrase you
can hope it's so cliche but he really
does kind of captured the soul he
captures the humanity of Tommy Wiseau
and there's definitely stuff left out of
the book that shows a little bit more
kind of the scum enos of whistle I mean
think they definitely don't shy away
from on all of it they they show a lot
of the not just difficult but really
kind of you know bad stuff he did you
know while making this movie and even
the personal life and stuff like that
and they leave some of the worst stuff
out but again even the bad stuff they do
show which some could argue you know as
a good thing or a bad thing
they really do show kind of the best way
that can why he's doing this which it's
a very strange mindset obviously the
time he was so has but they do show they
use human and that's something where
you kept up with us we've had many
run-ins with Tommy with so it's easy for
us to forget that it's it's easy for
anyone to forget that someone is human
and I think this film does a good job at
still finding that humanity saying that
ok no even though we can't always follow
it it still comes from a very very human
place and I think Tommy was so see
here's the thing cuz people are
complaining that they don't show enough
of him being you know like said they're
really mean or moments from the book I'd
argue there are quite a few in there but
it's but maybe I'm seeing that because
Tommy Wiseau is kind of like the perfect
joke he's very funny to watch when he's
abusing other people when you're the one
being abused it's not as funny so when
you're when I'm watching this and I'm
seeing him be really mean to this cast
and crew and making these insane demands
and not giving him water and keeping the
heat up and showing up late and having
him pass out and stuff like that while
many people in the crowd are laughing
I'm going but he really did that to
these people I mean that this these are
really terrible things that he did but
when you hear his reasoning it it is
funny you know in comedy as they say is
tragedy plus time and everything and
this time has passed and hopefully a lot
of the actors and people that work on
this film have found the comedy in it it
sounds like a lot of them have um and
yes I say the the big element to it that
at first I thought I wasn't gonna like
cuz again I mean we've had many run-ins
with this guy he tried to take down an
interview we did the he gave permission
to to be interviewed and he's literally
interviewed and and he said take it down
but again I think this movie very much
shows it comes from a human place that
doesn't mean we can't be happy with him
or angry with him depending on whether
he's happy with us are angry with us
whatever but it all comes from a human
place and I think that's why the film
works so well and I think it's why it's
doing so well that's why it's getting so
much praise and that's why people are
talking Oscar buzz about because it's
while it's definitely mocking him too
it is showing the humanity and I know
some people have a problem with that
trust me I get it but at the same time I
think it's an important element to have
in there and I think it's it's important
to have in there because I think that
also represents why the film the room is
so beloved because it does come from a
passionate place it does come from a
very human place even though we always
make fun of Fame what is he an alien
what is that like we can't follow this
mindset but we can follow it just enough
to laugh at it there's just enough human
in there for us to recognize and laugh
at and we recognize the starting point
we just don't know how it got to the
finishing point so you know in between
is the Tommy Wiseau filter so I think
that's why this film is having such a
strong reaction with people even people
haven't seen the movie you know and at
the end of this film they show
side-by-side comparisons of their
version of making the room and then the
original room is side-by-side and how
close they got it and I really feel like
they did this for two reasons one is to
show really how close they got it which
is very impressive maybe we've done side
by side stuff like this too and it's
it's tricky so I mean the fact that they
got it down that well is really
something to be admired but the other
thing in my opinion is I think they did
to show you know this isn't an act this
really is how was so was acting and how
he talks and everything because I feel
like if somebody went into this movie
totally blind knowing nothing about the
room they'd say well what the hell is
Franco doing that that's not a real
person that that's a cartoon that's a
caricature but it is it's a person so I
feel that was good to show at the end it
wait till after the credits again
without giving too much away just to
show how eerily well James Franco gets
Tommy Wiseau I mean the the particularly
the voice and the inflections it's
really amazing and I say with you know
cast opposite James Franco's gonna
steal the show everyone's gonna talk
about him but I feel dave Franco again
really kind of brings this humanity to
to Greg Sestero you know showing that he
that he does see something in Tommy and
Acer shows again this sort of an
exaggerated way but it shows how kind of
lost he was and why she would kind of be
interested in Tommy I feel they showed
both visually and through dialogue they
show it very very well and just the
acting as well they show it's it's not
stret me it's it's strange to see why he
would go with this guy but they
explained it in a way where you
understand you understand the
strangeness I think that's probably the
greatest accomplishment of the film is
that while it is still odd you follow it
better than you think you would follow
it you you feel like you understand both
Greg and Tommy more through these
performances and the book explains it
wonderfully you know but it's one of
those things where because the narration
isn't in there you know both since taro
and missiles and narration it isn't in
there you have to go entirely by
dialogue though I thought the script
supervisor played by I don't think he's
gonna get enough credit to Seth Rogen
it's really really good I feel like he's
kind of the narrator he's the common
he's the commentary saying we'll wait
why would or how would have you seen
interviews with this guy you did Seth
Rogen is a brilliant casting choice I
thought he really really nailed it I
mean he got what this guy is about how
he pretty much did Coker Co direct the
film it looks like I'm even taking out
what he said interviews and stuff like
that I mean they you just watch this
move and he'd be like oh he's that's
like the co-director you know he's
saying do we watch and rotation we try
he's the one being more responsible half
the time so I'm glad they really can't
put focus on that too so yeah I'm trying
to think what else is this something
where I think it's gonna win like Oscars
and stuff like that I think you'll get
nominated I don't know if it'll win I
think it's too weird
I think it's equivalent of like nominate
John
for Jack Sparrow it's like it's it's
nominated great I don't think it's gonna
win I think it's it's too far out there
but you know but but it's already
winning award that's already winning
Best Actor and stuff like that so again
it's just something where I'm I'm so
happy to see this come as far as it has
I think it's really phenomenal even when
all the was going on with you
know good time he was so trying to take
us down stuff like that I still said go
see the room I mean it's just it's
really amazing and now we have something
else really amazing from it too we have
you know that this wonderful film
directed by James Franco who I really do
not see in this performance this is
really every time he's on screen I'm
like okay I'm watching Tommy what so I'm
listening to Tommy what so and I don't
see them as brothers either I think that
it's really easy sometimes to kind of
see like you know oh well they're acting
like they're family they're acting like
it's like no but they they seem like
friends and they seem like two very very
different people they're served two
sides of a different coin and I really
didn't feel like oh that's just two
brothers working off each other I felt
like these were two very separate very
different people so yeah I I think
that's about it I think it's just it's
it's so cool I mean it's just not only
that this is out there and that it has
you know just all these little cameos in
it and and and celebrities making these
little guest appearances and that's a
critical hit and that it sounds like
it's an audience hit and I'm I'm sure
it's gonna be a big in the box office
really hope it is there were lines
around the block when I went when I went
to the music box so I'm hoping this is
as big a hit as it can be and just again
to Greg Sestero mad props to you man I
mean I literally just talked with you
before filming this but I just really
want to say mad props to you again man I
mean it's just anything in Hollywood is
difficult to get done and I just
remember from talking to you about you
know the review to you talking about the
bug to the the movie come out and
everything it's just it's so cool and I
really think you made a great story and
James
I made a phenomenal film and it's just
it's a lot of funny you do not need to
have seen the room in order to laugh at
it you will laugh more if you have but
you do not need to see it I think it's
it's an easy film to sit down and just
pick up and start watching and see all
the strange places it goes and I think
again that just comes from how strange
it is how funny it is but it is still
how touching it is - and it never quite
feels for its there's definitely movie
moments that that you need to do I mean
they condense stuff down from the book
but but you need to is so the story
flows more and it really works it just
really works and everything that needs
to hit really hits nothing ever felt
distracting it's it's just a solid great
movie about a solid bad movie that in
and of itself became great so guys
that's about it go check it out I'm sure
you're already gonna try to see it
already it's everything they're saying
is right it's a really cool funny you
know strange surreal wonderful film and
you should definitely go check it out so
if you haven't already go see it have a
great time and if a lot of people learn
to love each other the world would be a
better place to live take care
you